well we have a few minutes for questions
not too many let me remind you the
discipline una one theory we will
continue and we will have a real debate
I hope this afternoon but we have a few
minutes for some questions if anybody
wants to take the opportunity now yours
raise your hand professor reasonably you
have a microphone there question of
clarification to Chris hope the way I
understand your uncertainty the
probability distributions that you are
drawing it start from a range of values
for each of the parameters that go into
it generate Sims simulate the outcomes
and death does generate the distribution
of outcomes now it seems to me that's
not quite the uncertainty that one would
look my way of thinking you have a joint
distribution of values for the
parameters and depending upon the joint
distributions and how they interact the
parameters interact in the model you
generate the distribution of outcomes
it's true that you don't have enough
information to put together a joint
information joint distribution but why
not start with some prior distribution
and see with as information comes in
update the prior distribution and see
what sort of outcome probability
distribution of outcomes as generates
this is more it's not uncertainty per se
it's simulations distribution of
simulations rather than distribution of
outcomes in a probabilistic sense if I
understand you correctly it's a very
fair point
what's actually done is you're trying
all the time with all the different
parameters that you've got in
uncertainty ranges for to get an
encompass encompassing the ranges that
there are in the literature or in the
research that's why you end up with one
and a half to five degrees for climate
sensitivity and so on you don't want to
pick one number you want to use those
and then you do run those through as
joint probability distributions all the
way through the model that's how it
works you run 10,000 times with the
model picking from each of these
distributions and building up a
probability distribution for the output
built based on these joint probability
distributions for the inputs now you
have to be quite clever if you think
there's correlations between the inputs
and I talked in one of the experiments
there about having correlated inputs
most of the time what you want to try
and do is design your model so you don't
have lots of correlated inputs you want
to design it in a clever way so you can
have fairly independent inputs but
sometimes you do have to have those
correlations in there and that is
possible in the model and you can run
with correlated input distributions and
work out what the output distribution is
and as the last slide show for the value
of information then you can then talk
about what happens if you get better
information at some point in the future
and you do some hedging strategy up to
then and when you get the bit of
information you split the strategies up
according to the information that you
get and that can tell you something
about how much that information is worth
to you and I am shouted the value of
information for a scientific parameter
the climate sensitivity obviously it
will be nice to have it in there for
things like the impact function exponent
one of the things that make highlighted
is being very important and the value of
extra information about that it will be
very good to see what that is now and
you need to see how all those numbers
change you know posts turn they were all
priests our numbers runs done before the
stone review came out so I think I'm
going to be busy for a few months trying
to get those poster numbers out
yes how useful and significant would be
policies that accelerate the demographic
transition I think the policies that
accelerate demographic transition are
valuable in their own right I mean there
is they're essentially reasonably well
understood now I think its job
opportunities for women education for
girls and women access to reproductive
health services and those are the kinds
of things which we know from looking at
the way in which fertility rates have
dropped saying Bangladesh from six to
three over the last 25 or 30 years I
think we understand roughly speaking
what drives those things and they seem
to me to be policies which it makes good
sense to follow anyway a lot to do with
human rights a lot to do with economic
development and so on they would help of
course the with the challenge of global
warming but I wouldn't particularly want
to go that route in arguing for those
policies I think I'd want to argue them
both for them in their own rights if you
want to use that as a supplementary
argument that's fine but I don't think
you have to
hi this is another clarifying question I
didn't get a sense in the model how
reduced form it was do you actually try
to trace out the future of energy
consumption and decide when the
transition from oil to coal is taking
place and so on or are you just making
an assumption about how fast the
temperature is going to rise and an
assumption about how costly it is of the
temperature rises I'm are you figuring
out how much the temperature is going to
rise on the basis of exactly which
technology is being used at which time
and and if so I'm just curious how long
you're projecting oil is going to last
and things like that it's a good
question the answer is it's a very
reduced form model it doesn't have
anything in there in terms of an
explicit modeling of the energy sector
so different fuels and so on it starts
at the point of saying what the
emissions of the different greenhouse
gases are so you need to feed into the
model what the emissions of co2 are
going to be methanesulfonyl fluoride the
other gases that are important in terms
of causing climate change and from there
you can work out what's going to happen
to the concentrations the forcing the
temperature all the while bringing in
the chain of uncertainties that Nicholas
has been talking about and working
through to the impacts at the end and
getting the uncertainties there so it
doesn't have an explicit energy model on
the front of it it would be nice to have
one there but it has a lot of the work
in the IPCC has gone on into building up
that kind of emission pathway that they
are already made for us to use I decided
that wasn't the best way of using the
the effort on this model on the cost
side we did try to know you think ask
yourself the question how can you start
to control the emissions and get them to
peak in 20 years time and gradually come
down and in looking at that we did try
to look at the possibilities of
different kinds of technologies and when
they might come in I mentioned we looked
at the cost of trying to limit 25 50
along the kinds of pars I described
and there there is an implicit timing in
one of those approaches that we took
because we did look at the different
technologies asked when they might start
to come in and then you do get the
different balance of energy use from
that kind of thing but it's not into the
not integrated into that full model my
own view on these models is that at some
point you've got to try to stop loading
lots of things in and we looked in the
hole at the on the hole at the cost side
separately from that overall modeling
because you can get involved in much
more detail than you can you could
possibly handle in a grand model yep
thanks I have another question for dr.
hope regarding the page model I'm
curious about the choice of the a2 sres
scenario as the the scenario underlying
the run used or that was used in the
stern review I know a number of the
assumptions used in that s various in
our a particularly population but also
economic growth rates may become
somewhat problematic especially if you
extend the model out to 2200 and I'm
curious if you've tried running the page
model with say the a1 f or a 1b
scenarios and how that changes the
outcome yeah one reason for using the a2
scenario was that it's one of the only
two scenarios in the third IPCC report
that had some probabilistic information
on it there were several runs which you
could use to say roughly what sort of
range of answers might come out if you
use that scenario the other one that was
putting that kind of detail with
scenario be too and I've done quite a
lot of runs with scenario B 2 as well
and the third one which has come along
since the IPCC is the common polls image
scenario business as usual and they if
you look carefully at the last couple of
slides where I was talking about optimal
scenarios and values of information you
would have seen that the
business-as-usual scenario for that one
was the CPI the common polls image
scenario so you can run whatever you
like as being your business as usual
scenario put some month certainty around
it the model allows you to do that and
then see what impact that
on the answer but it's a good question
you ought to be very wary about just
taking one scenario one of the
interesting results that seems to come
out of the model is that the social cost
of carbon doesn't seem to vary very much
depending on which scenario you impose
it on and if you want to know the reason
for that I suggest we do it in
discussion because it's quite a complex
reason which took a few runs to find out
why that was it doesn't matter for the
balanced growth equivalent of course
because you get quite a heavy population
load in the a21 and that's why we did
some back-of-the-envelope sensitivity to
see what difference working with lower
populations might make given the same
kinds of emissions it does bring down
the damages somewhat and was in the
table that I put up I'd like to ask
another question about the social cost
of carbon and dr. hope talked about
social cost of carbon under a
business-as-usual scenario and I wonder
Nick if you could give us your thoughts
on something which I know is a kind of
an issue for policymakers which is there
whether the appropriate social cost of
carbon to use in policymaking is the
business as usual social cost of carbon
or the significantly lower social cost
of carbon associated with a
stabilization trajectory 25 50 parts per
million Ne Ne shadow price which is a
marginal concept of course is
problematic in a whole modeling
structure where you're dealing with in
the model itself very big non marginal
effects and if further you're dealing
with policies which themselves could
make very big differences that means
that you have to be very careful to
attach to any estimate of the social
cost of carbon a statement about the
kind of pass to which it corresponds and
Chris was very explicit his social cost
of carbon attached itself to the
business as usual path so suppose you
take the business as usual path with
these rising emissions and you perturb
it a little bit at a given point of time
what happens to the subsequent past and
then the difference between the two is
the damage caused by the extra carbon if
you look at social cost of carbon around
a past which is more sensible in the
discrepancy stabilization at 550 parts
per million then because you are
adopting sensible policies into the
future in terms of controlling emissions
the social cost of carbon will be lower
because the stocks of emissions over
time will be lower so it's a classic
example in applied cost-benefit analysis
of needing to be explicit about the
relationship between the shallow price
and the overall path which is being
followed it does of course make a
difficulty for the policymaker because
suppose you're trying to look at the
social cost of carbon in the context of
a project which is a road building
project which will save some travel time
and save some petrol what price do you
use for the carbon associated with the
petrol gasoline i should say here which
is saved well you've gotta take of you
if you think the world's going to be
sensible you'll have a lower price if
you think the world's not going to be
sensible about controlling climate
change you'll have a higher price and it
seems to me that if that really matters
to the investment decision that's being
taken you have to look at it very hard
and see what kind of probabilities there
are of different kinds of policies out
there may be some of the time you won't
have to be that precise but there is a
problem with the social cost of carbon
he's just how big these differences are
and that's why in the presentation that
i gave i didn't lay a lot of emphasis in
the social cost of carbon is a policy
tool and what we argued was that you
should get from the point of view of the
economics of risk of the Marty Weitzman
kind you should set stabilization goals
and find the past associated with them
there'll be a corridor of parts
associated with any given stabilization
goal and you use your price make
ism's to decentralize within that
corridor of paths but revising from time
to time as the information of the kind
that Chris described comes in and in
that revision some sort of feel that
social cost of carbon would actually be
helpful but we didn't set it up as the
central driving force of the policy
decentralization story as we described
it is very well aware of the political
process I tend to think of the social
cost of carbon as being what you should
use to set any carbon tax that you might
have and i would agree very much with
nick that what you want to do probably
is look at what the carbon tax should be
under an optimal path of emissions roll
and under a business as usual path of
emissions and i actually think you
should probably set your carbon tax as
being a little bit higher than the mean
social cost of carbon for various
reasons to do with the things that have
been missed out of the calculations but
also to do with the fact that you're
going to be replacing other taxes which
do nasty things in the economy but it's
still even if you accept that it's still
I think an open research question as to
just how much the social cost of carbon
varies if you go from something like a
business-as-usual scenario to something
like an optimal path omissions over time
it may be a drops by a factor of two or
three maybe it doesn't drop very much at
all and it seems to depend quite a lot
on what you assume about what's going to
happen to other gases like sulfates and
another background gases in the
atmosphere as you go to your optimal
path of emissions so you know something
else to work on over the next few weeks
which is nice you had a question you
know yep
was the acidification of the oceans
included in the social class ethnicity
thank you um the the page model as a run
for this kind of study doesn't take into
account the other impacts that there
might be of fossil fuel use let's say so
it doesn't take into account explicitly
the other co benefits that there are
from reducing fossil fuel use some of
which is acid rain acidification
reduction and so on it is possible to
run the model with other models which
track through those things explicitly
and find out the total benefit of
cutting back let's say emissions of
fossil fuel from fossil fuel but you
have to be quite careful how you do that
because obviously if you're some of your
policy action is to reduce the emissions
of co2 by reducing deforestation well
that won't necessarily give you the same
kinds of co-benefits as you get from
reducing co2 by reducing the burning of
fossil fuels so it's probably better to
put that in as a as an explicit second
things to model to find out the
co-benefits rather than to put it into
the model of greenhouse effect itself I
think it's a good example of why you'd
want to go for these disaggregated
descriptions I mean chapters three four
five before we got to chapter six we did
look across a whole range of these kinds
of problems and the decision challenge
then is would you pay one percent of GDP
to drastically reduce this whole
collection of types of risk and that's
why I feel that the first way of looking
at it before you get into the detailed
modeling which suppresses so much of
what's interesting is very valuable and
we should see these two approaches as
there's one complementing or one
supporting the other but that is an
example that's what I had in mind about
what you lose when you go to the
inevitably simple simple models that are
the only ones you can handle we have
time just for one question you have been
waiting
and then I have to it's a very short
comment there was a lot of mention about
climate sensitivity and I think just
wanted to the IPCC process takes models
from all the countries in the world who
are able to submit there is really no
quality control there is no way to check
there is a model democracy and all the
PDF that you get is based on how good
the different models are and the
assumption is that since it is a
nonlinear dynamical system that's the
inherent uncertainty of the
parameterization and model but if you
take a view that those models which are
doing good in simulating the current
climate should be considered more
reliable for the future climate for
which there is no basis you find out
that the sensitivity is at the highest
range of the IPCC estimates so this is
something that the IPCC has decided to
get into that is starting from the next
assessment but and when the actual
report will come out in a few months
these results will be mentioned somehow
but the any estimates based on the model
credibility give you the sensitivity to
be the highest in the range sobering
thought I think that's an example of the
kinds of ways in which we were cautious
we didn't know how to go forward to
incorporate those kinds of possibilities
but there are strong signs in the IPCC
report and maybe they didn't go fast far
enough for me know more about that than
I do but I do think there are lots of
uncertainties out there and risks of a
major kind which is simply not in the
story as we told it runs with these
higher numbers that seem to be coming
through from Murphy and staying forth
and so on they seem to increase the mean
values for the social cost of carbon by
at least fifty percent possibly a little
bit more and so it's exactly why you
need this kind of model when you get
better information you see what effect
it has on the policy relevant numbers
well and we run out of time so allow me
yours to give dienes path the
opportunity of having the last word in
his morning session
I will be brief I promise first I just
have to own behalf of everyone here
express thanks to Nick and his
colleagues for what they've done for
what they've done in this remarkable
report for coming to Yale and spending
the day with us and even more for
putting up with Washington and making
the presentations in Washington we think
that was probably the biggest
contribution you could possibly make the
this is obviously the most comprehensive
economic analysis that's been done it
will be a point of departure and
reference for all future work I see four
main points coming out of it first that
the risks are very great secondly that
the time is very short at least in two
senses one is that the gases are
building up rapidly and we may miss the
opportunity to move to that window
between 450 and 550 parts per million
and secondly because the cost of
stabilizations is increasing as the
report points out thirdly that action
has got to be very significant the
report calls for sixty to eighty percent
reduction in the rich countries probably
by 2050 and fourthly that the cost of
mitigation can be affordable you make
these points very clearly persuasively
and we're in your debt for making them
people will argue about many aspects of
the report I'm sure but I suspect at
these four points these four basic
conclusions will stand up and be very
robust the good news for all of us here
in the United States is that this
country has finally come alive with the
issue we seem to have passed through
some threshold where it's going to be
essentially impossible for politicians
to ignore it as they have successfully
done for the last quarter century I
can't resist mentioning the fact that it
was way back in the Carter
Administration
when we said things like the carbon
dioxide problem should be taken
seriously in new ways it should become a
factor in making energy policy and not
simply the subject of scientific
investigation that was 27 years ago I
also have to admit that we said
something like this to in particular we
cannot presume that in order to decide
whether to proceed with the carbon
dioxide experiment we can accurately
assess the long-term costs and benefits
of unprecedented changes in global
climate so but anyhow here we are we
just did it didn't we but the fact that
we wasted a quarter century or more here
in getting busy with this problem leads
the discern review to say things like
when it talks about what can be done to
use the phrase like avoid the worst
because this is now a chronic disease
that our planet has and we will be
coping with it for a long long time the
momentum in the u.s. obviously started
in the states and local governments
california's commitment to eighty
percent reduction by 2020 New York City
is putting in place Mayor Bloomberg a
really aggressive program and Yale has
itself adopted a forty-three percent
reduction goal by 2020 it's now moved to
Washington and Congress has flooded with
cap and trade proposals and I think we
should be excited that it long last this
is happening but we have to temper our
euphoria with the knowledge that it'll
be a long hard slog a long hard fight to
get where we need to be on this problem
and we haven't got much time in
conclusion I have to say Nick that I'm
one of those who worries that you may
have set the stabilization target at a
level that is could be could well turn
out to be dangerous too dangerous I
afraid at least based on my reading
which is a layman's reading almost that
somewhere but at this range of 450 parts
per million see
two equivalent to 550 is an
extraordinarily important range and at
the low end of that range we will
probably have impacts that are that will
could live with but at the high end of
that range we're in a too dangerous a
territory then the my reading found
footnote 23 in the document that you've
provided us in subsequent work on the
since the report and it mentions that at
550 co2e there's a 50-50 chance of
exceeding temperatures of three degrees
Celsius built build up and that this
could lead to up to sixty percent more
people at risk from hunger with half the
increase in Africa and West Asia more
than 1 billion people may suffer water
shortages many in Africa the ecosystems
will be destroyed in between twenty and
fifty percent of species faced
extinction serious droughts in Europe
and California could occur as often as
once every 10 years in the risk of
abrupt and major events such as the
onset of irreversible melting of the
Greenland ice sheet increased
dramatically and it indeed does because
this three degrees global average is
probably six or more over Greenland and
this is why of course the European Union
has tried to avoid a goal of as high as
three degrees running that risk by
talking about a goal of two degrees and
a maximum of two degrees i should say
and people like Jim Hansen and many
others believe we have to come in below
that level to really be safe and so
we're back down at this end of the
spectrum of from 450 to 550 that's very
very close to 550 if we want to avoid
and not run a big risk of this three
degree or plus global average warming
indeed the report itself mentions that
if greenhouse gas levels could be
stabilized at today's levels
430 co2e mean global temperatures would
eventually rise to about one point one
to three degrees above the
pre-industrial level so you have to ask
well one two three that's an important
range what might we have already done
having raised the gases up to four
hundred and thirty co2e and the report
goes on to say that it had been
sensitivity analysis done and that these
sensitivities imply that there is up to
a one in five chance that the world
would experience the warming in excess
of three degrees Celsius above the
predetermined levels even if greenhouse
gas concentrations were stabilized at
today's level of 430 parts per million
in other words there's a twenty percent
chance that we've already bought the
ranch here and and so any sort of
progression much beyond that strikes me
as quite dangerous and so I just repeat
what I was saying earlier it does seem
to me that there is this range that that
you have covered is the critical range
between something that we will have to
live with and could live with at some
level of damage and and and and true
true danger true extraordinary risk as
Jim Hanson's as an alternative planet or
ruined planet so I think it makes a big
difference and and so when I see the
Wonder one a couple of times Nick you
know didn't pick the mid range of the
450 to 550 to talk about or even the low
range but when for example the costs
were one percent it was 550 and a couple
of times I think I heard the phrase
stabilize at 550 or something of that
effect and I would just say that it
strikes me as as important to make
distinctions in that in that range and
and as much as possible we should be
focusing very heavily on the bottom of
that range but that's a
my own little comment you'll have many
other comments this afternoon from
people who have are very expert and I'm
sure that it will be a wonderful
discussion this afternoon and again
thank you so much for coming and
contributing and for doing this report
and going to Washington appreciate